the Joe Rogan experience we wanted to
get one here we're probably gonna wind
up doing that get one here because you
have two showers and what the shower
Nexus song is kind of useless so who
uses the sauna here Jamie just me you
don't use this ani whose occasional
occasion yeah yeah I also had a gym I
was going to perhaps you do use this on
other right yeah yeah I use it everyday
I usually use it at home but sometimes I
use it here when I like right after
workouts like if I work out I try to get
a workout here before you know like
before I do podcasts and I'll time it so
they have an extra hour so I can get in
the sauna that's awesome
yeah it makes a big difference for me
but I also just I think it might be a
little too much before like I'm always
trying to regulate how much activity I
do with whether or not I'm gonna be
exhausted when I do a podcast because I
used to do yoga and then I would come
out I would get out of yoga at 11:00 or
at 10:30 and I would do a podcast at 12
and I was like I think I better wait
till 1:00 because I'd just be so because
90-minute yoga classes in the 105
degrees is [ __ ] rough it's intense
it's rough yeah I've only done Bikram a
couple times I would love to like do it
more I loved it
yeah I really loved it well I would
wonder and I know there's there's
supposedly some sort of Harvard study
that's ongoing right now measuring all
sorts of markers and people that have
done hot yoga and whether or not it
mimics heat shock proteins that are
created in the sauna because the thing
is like you are getting this incredible
cardiovascular exercises your heart's
beating like crazy and you know you're
not doing cardio per se but your heart
rate goes get jacked because of the heat
and the stress and then on top of that
even though it's only a hundred and five
degrees
your body is heating up you're you're
really sweating up a storm in there make
its I've taken some friends there that
have never experienced it before and
they're like [ __ ] you over come on
bro
and then they get in there and then I
look over at them 15 minutes then
they're like [ __ ] hey and I'm like
yeah it is told you it's not it's not
what you think it is because you're
doing like yoga you've been uncoupled
for
the heat stir like the hot part yoga is
is also like it's pretty intense like
folding those positions and stuff and
like your heart rate does start to
elevate I mean it's like just from that
alone adding on the sauna which mimics
moderate physical activity that's been
shown absolutely mimics it and then all
that you know studies that have shown
that on top of that I mean that's like
it's it's it's super intense it's super
intense the really cool thing about and
I want to get my mom I think once we
move the sauna like to our home where
it's not like the office like I want to
people that are not people that are
sedentary and people that are sedentary
for whatever reason maybe their
sedentary because they're disabled or
maybe their sedentary because they've
had a lifetime of being sedentary and
it's they it is just hard to get them
motivated to go exercise like the sauna
to me is like that's so important
because it's giving these people a
potential cardiovascular workout no it
is that's been shown it's giving them a
cardiovascular workout without having to
force them to go for a run or going on a
bike you know that people think like
when you tell them go sit in the sauna
they think of like a spa like yeah I
want to go do that you get someone who's
like like my mom who she's she's
sedentary you know she's not like a
physically active person and she needs
to be um but like the sauna that's
that's kind of my goal is to get our
doing and we'll have to start slowly
because you have to adapt you know the
heat shock proteins help with that as
you the more the more times you're
exposed to heat stress and the more
adapted you are like the the heat shock
proteins increased quicker and so it's
part of the adaptational process as well
of you know being able to handle the
heat stress but like I want to get her
to do that because like any you know any
cardiovascular improvements gonna help
her moon it's gonna help her her you
know all cause mortality that's been
shown you know four to seven times a
week forty forty percent lower all cause
mortality cardiovascular mortality these
fifty percent lower you know so like I
think that's a really cool thing about
the sauna is that you can get people
that are disabled people that can't go
for a run you know I mean I still think
exercise I mean it's just the best thing
ever no period for everything right you
know for everything it's just going to
overall improve the way
you age and that's going to make you
more robust and resilient to anything
yeah
Samet to me is McGuinn ziz that muscles
feel better they feel looser they've
they're not as sore like when I have
hard workouts and I get in the sauna
afterwards I feel like from my
recoveries more rapid interesting that's
interesting yeah I
because I don't do resistance training
shame on me I don't I don't have that
same perspective but it their-their
happen studies at least were localized
heat on people that had a limb
immobilized I don't remember what limit
was but after a week people that had the
heat treatment local heat treatment had
almost 40% less muscle atrophy and in
huge in animal studies and like I
remember I like shared this animal study
and an article I wrote years ago before
the humans said he came out and like
they're critical its animals and you
can't say it does this and I would get
on the mechanism and they showed it was
heat shock proteins and there was all
you know like and I was so happy when
that human study came out I was like
told you told you
[Laughter]
[Applause]